vamos a ver si podemos calcular cuánto
es 14 2 cuánto es 14 menos 4 y cuánto es
14 menos 6 y los anima a pausar este
vídeo y a tratar de descubrir estos
resultados antes de que yo lo resuelva
ok asumo que ya lo trataron de hacer
vamos a empezar tengo el número 14 y por
la forma en la que está escrito este
número podemos saber que es un grupo de
10 esto es lo que nos dice este 1 que
tenemos aquí más cuatro unidades vamos a
verificar que tenga 14 objetos aquí
abajo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 aquí tenemos
un grupo de 10 10 objetos y los voy a
marcar tengo 10 objetos en este grupo
y aquí tengo algunas unidades más 1 2 3
4 tengo cuatro unidades más esto es en
total 14 objetos este 1 que tenemos aquí
representa 10 un grupo de 10 objetos y
lo voy a escribir aquí abajo un grupo de
y luego tenemos 4 unidades 4 unidades
también escribo aquí abajo
estos son 14 objetos
ahora vamos a ver cada uno de estos
números cuánto es 14 menos 2
bueno pues quitamos 1 y quitamos 2 y
cuantos me quedan aquí me queda un grupo
completo de 10 así que puede escribir 1
aquí y luego escribir las unidades que
me quedan de este lado cuántas son 1 y 2
tengo dos unidades más así que 14 menos
2 es igual a 12
ahora vamos a calcular 14 menos 4 voy a
limpiar aquí para tener 14 completos
ahora sí
cuánto es 14 menos 4 tengo que quitar 4
quito 1 2 3 4 estoy quitando estas
cuatro unidades entonces que me queda
cuántos objetos me quedan ahora tengo mi
grupo completo de 10 y ya no tengo
unidades o tengo cero unidades
así que 14 menos 4 es igual a 10 y esto
tiene sentido si 14 es 10 más 4 y quito
las cuatro unidades entonces me quedan
10 déjenme escribirlo de este lado 14 es
igual a 10
+ 4 y le restó 4
aquí estoy restando 44 menos cuatro es
igual a cero así que nos quedan sólo
diez
podríamos decir diez más cero o
simplemente diez y podemos hacer lo
mismo aquí arriba 14 es igual a 10 más 4
y luego le restamos 2 el resultado va a
ser este 10 y cuánto es 4 menos 24 menos
dos es 2 por eso escribimos este 2 aquí
y voy a hacer esto un poco más claro
esto lo simplificamos como dos y es este
2 que escribimos aquí esto lo
simplificamos como 0 es este 0 que
escribimos aquí ahora vamos a hacer la
última cuánto es 14 menos 6
ahora tenemos que quitar 1 2 3 4 5
ahora sí estamos quitando de nuestro
grupo de 10
el resultado será ahora un número de un
dígito y nos quedan 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y 8 el
resultado aquí es 8 14 menos 6 es igual
a 8 terminamos